[Music]
what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
is just trying to get a lunch money
right we are here back in the studio
we have help jordy's here my brother the
ugly one is sitting over in the corner
but he won't show his face so you don't
notice what i'm talking about
and i have the intelligent and beautiful
polina
right here next to me don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block five has three products you
can buy and sell a
crypto on the crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy in that interest
bearing account
or you could deposit crypto and take out
a usd loan to get your crypto collateral
they're also coming out the credit card
where you can swipe your credit card
you'll get bitcoin rewards rather than
cash back or
airline miles go sign up at blackfy.com
pomp blockfy.com
go sign up what's up paulina all right
so this is the big story of the day
oh big story big story stanley
druckenmiller
um sorry
stanley druckenmiller says the fed is
endangering the dollar's global reserve
status he says i can't find any period
in history where monetary and fiscal
policy
were this out of step with the economic
circumstances
not one he said though he agreed with
the early steps the fed took during the
pandemic of all the
money printing et cetera thing he
said that the fed has kept its foot on
the gas
for too damn long what do you say did
you just say
i did one more time
no oh
stanley druckenmoth has been saying
exactly what bitcoin has been saying for
a while
and stanley draco miller also owns
bitcoin not a coin wait does he own
bitcoin yes
not a coincidence here's the deal is
when you
continue to print trillions and
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars
and then you print trillions and
trillions and trillions more you
have to devalue the currency and so what
we are watching
is central banks absolutely destroy
what we know as financial markets
because they believe
that you can continue to print as much
money
as they possibly need and it won't have
the negative side effects
and if they start to see negative side
effects they believe that they'll be
able to control inflation on the other
side
but now you are hearing this is not
bitcoiners this isn't laser-eyed
you know ludites on the internet that
everyone just scoffs at and says they
don't know what they're talking about
this is stanley druckenmiller stanley
druckenmiller is one of the best
investors in wall street
he's literally compounded money at over
30 percent
for more than a decade two decades three
decades i think he's been doing it for
30 plus years
and he's performed at the highest levels
on wall street there's not a person on
wall street that doesn't respect
what stanley druckenmiller does when he
says i'm going on television
he went on television to explain an
op-ed that he put i think it was in the
wall street journal
and they gave him like 30 minutes on
cnbc
when stanley jackie miller says i got
something to say wall street
shuts up and listens and for stanley
druckenmiller to be saying
he believes that in the next 15 years
the u.s dollar is going to lose global
reserve status because of actions being
taken today
you better believe the federal reserve
the treasury
politicians and every single financial
institution on wall street
peaked up and said whoa why and they're
asking questions this morning so stanley
druckenmiller's saying exactly what
bitcoin has been saying for a long time
only the person who's delivering the
message is really really important
and uh he said if they want to do all
this and risk our reserve currency
status
risk an asset bubble blowing up so be it
but i think we ought to at least have a
conversation about it
so does he feel like he's like i feel
like he's like ringing the alarm bell
because nobody's even talking about that
this is even a possibility
well again this is what i've been saying
bitcoin has to understand
the economy better than wall street and
the central bankers
what you are seeing is you are seeing an
academic exercise
play out and the reason why everyone
isn't talking about it
is because everyone's getting rich this
is good for rich people it's literally
what i've been saying for a year now
is when they print money they are
enriching
the rich people and they are making the
poor people poorer well guess what the
poor people
the bottom 45 percent of americans they
don't have a voice
there is nobody in the bottom 45 percent
that has a say
this is not a democratic process this is
simply central banks who are
manipulating
currencies and interest rates in a way
with the guise of we're helping people
but really what they're doing is they're
making rich people richer
and poor people poor and so now what you
have is you have one of the richest men
in america raising his hand and he's
saying hey
this is good right now everyone's
getting rich but so was everyone in
weimar
germany every single person thought they
were getting rich
until hyperinflation happened and so
what we have to be careful of
is while everyone's getting rich where
are we going
stop focusing on where we are today
where are we going
and if you continue to devalue currency
and you continue to print money you're
likely to go to a place that no one
wants to go
so wake up stop printing money stop
systematically devaluing the currency
and stop
punishing the people that need help the
most
and rant i feel like what's going on
right now is kind of an exercise and
like
theory versus like how the real world
works
all these people were saying like oh but
academically speaking like this is how
things should be
and then it's like that's not how the
world works
in many different ways and this is just
one of them
okay speaking of this is not how the
world works um
schools across the world have been
kind of focused on discipline and
compliance and
not cooperation just like silence and
like
i can't i can't explain it you know what
i'm trying to say in school
they tell you come here kids sit down
be quiet and do what we say right and
they teach the kids what's the word
what's obedience is the word they teach
them fit within the system
they teach them hey if we literally
break your will to be creative to be
innovative
to do what you want to do to follow your
passion
to ultimately be happy we then can
convince you
to go take on loads of debt or we can
take
you and convince you to go work in
factories in the industrial age
school was built in a way for a world
where it was important to break the will
of people and get them to go into the
workforce
with the belief that they had to be
obedient and they had to
listen but not anymore we are no longer
in the industrial age
so we invested in synthesis
separately we invested separately in
synthesis they raised five million
dollars in series a funding at a 50
million
valuation okay i'm done i led the series
a investment in synthesis
it was a school uh inside of spacex that
elon musk built for his kids
there was one course called synthesis
that is spun out now into this software
product
uh it is co-founded by the co-creator of
that school with elon
and a software engineer from class dojo
named chrisman frank
they've got a bunch of teachers that
they've hired including our friend anna
lorena fabriga
and when i did the seed round and then
the series a
they made a list internally unbeknownst
to me
of all the people that they wanted to
invest in the company and next thing i
know polina says
oh i talked to them they want me to
angel and invest i'm gonna do it
i said okay so pelena has made
so i'm in his round polina has made an
angel investment congratulations
thank you nice work it's a great deal
just so happens we both think it's a
good deal
uh and so if you have a kid between the
ages of seven to 14
you should go to synthesis.is
synthesis.is and go sign up
your kid will learn problem solving
skills complex thinking
mental models so i know you said it's
like a software product but it's
important to note that it's not
just software the software is kind of
like the fuel
it's a game that you can play remotely
but
there's a lot of collaboration with the
kids over zoom so they're actually
talking and they're getting excited and
they're doing leadership skills like
for example i watched a video they call
these magic moments
where they look at the kids in a session
and they're like oh my god look at this
like 11 year old kid
being like you know what guys i think he
should be the leader because he does
really well under pressure i don't think
i should do it and like stepping away to
be like
stop it stepping away to be like look my
buddy is like better at me than this and
i recognize that i'm super self-aware so
let's just get it done because we have
11 minutes left and you see how
like kids can collaborate and work
better than you see at some of these
like
companies if you want your kid to be
successful in the real world
go sign them up for synthesis if you're
cool trusting
your kids future and your kids education
to
the system to the industrial education
complex
leave them in school don't worry about
it don't even go to the website but
synthesis.is may have the keys to unlock
your kid's future potential all right
next
back to the economy the us economy
is trying to restart itself from the
pandemic it's kind of sputtering it's
kind of like an old car you're like
and then you got to push it okay
apparently parts of it are severely
broken can you tell i come from bulgaria
um okay okay nevermind
um so the country faces major shortages
and everything from labor to
semiconductors lumber and packaging
materials
the scan the scarcity is not only
preventing the economy from reaching its
full potential
but also raising fears of higher
inflation as companies are forced to
hike
prices these shortages both labor and
non-labor will affect
the speed under which the economy
recovers says barclays head of economics
research
michael gapen literally this is a far
different tune than we saw literally
last week last week it was like u.s
economy back on track now it's
u.s economy can't restart what's going
on tyson foods is a 30 billion dollar
food supplier
the average increase of prices for tyson
foods
last quarter last quarter
was seven point five percent that means
that literally chicken costs seven and a
half percent more on average even my
chicken nuggets
all of it the cost of goods
is exploding there is
business after business industry after
industry
that is deciding to raise prices between
five and ten percent
and yet we are being told by the federal
reserve it's so confusing that the
inflation number is sub
two percent so maybe we shouldn't trust
the numbers
coming from the organizations that are
financially incentivized to lie to us
if you believe inflation is under two
percent you're an idiot
that's that's what i believe if you
believe that inflation is actually under
two percent
you are a first-class idiot and so then
it begs the question
well what is inflation is it 2.1
or is it 10 and the truth is
nobody actually knows the real answer
everyone has a different methodology of
how you measure it
but what we do know is it's not the
number they're telling us
it's much higher and what we also know
is that the cost of goods is exploding
and we have a government administration
and a federal reserve and a treasury
that continues to believe
that they can just go do whatever they
want
and there will be no negative
consequences and that my friends is not
the way the world works
well do you think that they were saying
all of that to kind of like soothe fears
and like calm things down even though on
the ground
it is not the reality and people are
smart enough to see that
so let's say that's what they were doing
are they then admitting that they were
lying to people they knew something that
would not be true and they still told
people that
well i don't know i'm not saying that
that's what they're doing i don't know
but if that's
the argument is oh we are simply just
saying something to soothe people's
fears
well the other way to describe that on a
factual basis would be they would be
lying
so i actually think that they believe
the numbers that they're
sharing i don't think that they're
they're maliciously doing it but i also
think that the way that they have
screwed around
with the methodology of calculating
these numbers
is completely inaccurate and when you
actually look at the ground
the reality of what's occurring and you
look at all of the data points
you can see the cost of goods is
exploding and it ain't two percent
and so we have a choice either you can
sit
and say hey the government the federal
reserve etc is here to save me
they're going to look out for me and i'm
going to trust them
or you can say regardless of what they
do if it's right or wrong i'm gonna make
sure that i'm protected
your choice you know where i stand all
right moving on to
more fun news a goldman sachs london
managing director has
is said to have quit after making a
fortune on dogecoin
they're savage allegedly sources say i'm
not sure how much
but this man aziz mcmahon a managing
director and head of emerging market
sales at goldman sachs in london has
resigned
allegedly after making money on dogecoin
does it say how much it does not i mean
if you work at goldman sachs and you're
the head of emerging market sales
you probably get paid a pretty nice
penny a nice penny
and so it's not like the guy made 100k
or 500k my guess
is that the guy made 10 plus million
dollars that's
wild i mean that'd be my guess
right like if you're working at goldman
sachs and you make that type of money
do you really quit over a million bucks
probably not probably not right like
i don't know maybe he did but maybe he
was already gonna quit and this was his
excuse and he just hated his job
who knows for sure but it's got to be a
pretty serious amount of cash
hat dogecoin actually
okay moving on to next the next story
and i have a bone to pick with you and i
had to find this out in the press
bringing it here publicly to you guys
first he doesn't even know i have a bone
typical goat
time time so mark zuckerberg
shared a photo of his two goats saying
that
his pet goats are named bitcoin and max
upon
seeing this news he told me and what i
said was ha ha isn't it funny that he
could be making a statement
of that he's a bitcoin maximalist
because i'm good at puns
so i just said that and then he tweeted
it and then
it ends up in this article saying morgan
creek digital co-founder anthony
pompliano chimed in
to ask whether zuckerberg is telling us
he is a bitcoin
maximalist with the names of his goats
nowhere do i
see credit nowhere do i see hat tip
hold on what am i hold on cooked meat
wait what are they chopped to liver
i forgot the phrase stick to your
bulgarian phrase
let me defend myself let me defend
myself let me defend myself
tell me stealing content from my mind
you said something
factually and i had to go to the people
you said factually that's what it meant
and i said let me
ask the people what they think and i
asked a question do you know what a
question mark is
do they have those in bulgaria but
where's my credit
you don't get credit i was asking a
question you were saying a fact
and my guess is that your fact is
inaccurate oh my god
i was asking a question to the people
the people have the answers
you don't have the answers house way how
you're wrong sway if you don't know the
story behind how sway how just google
kanye west how sway it's ask lunch money
time
wait are you gonna apologize to me
no this is i'm about to it's copyrighted
i like this microphone like this because
i can get real crazy with it okay
anthony it gets crazy on the editing
ask lm time please enter your questions
below
i didn't see any good questions so this
is my time to ask a question to you guys
right now you have a website up that it
says build habits develop a daily
exercise habit
eat foods that make your brain bigger
how to build training habits like magnus
carlson
okay i'm reading about magnus carl what
do you spend all day putting in your
brain
i'm reading about magnus carlsen and
okay fun fact this is what we're gonna
do
fun fact he's a chess grandmaster but
i could beat him no every single day he
does a 30 to 60 minute run on the
treadmill
an hour or two of soccer basketball
tennis hiking or skiing
and that's during tournaments when he's
trying to conserve
energy he says that running is a time
where i can go through game strategies
so if you're a chess player you my
friend are an athlete
that is all i have to say just because
you run on the treadmill it doesn't make
you an athlete okay skiing hiking soccer
i've seen you run on the treadmill and
let's just say i wouldn't classify you
as an athlete
and that's it for today guys bye guys